there was Jordan Peterson who people
could actually emulate because he's
worthy of being emulated and then he
kind of fell off cuz he obviously had
some personal issues going on and
whatnot and then there was this vacuum
where men were still being abused
socially being told that you know the
ways that they behave are not acceptable
that they need to change and shift and
do all these sort of things in order to
fit in with society and I think what
that speaks to is the fact that there's
no male role models that are worthy of
replacing like a Jordan Peterson that
has good messaging has a good moral
frame work whatever that looks like for
the individual and is able to talk to
men at their level and so instead what
you get are these Andrew Tate type
figures who have filled that void
because no one else could fill it and so
in a way we kind of created this monster
ourselves